[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في برنامج من المصدر المجله
الاسبوعيه المخصصه لتحليل المشهد الاعلامي
وبحث قضايا الاعلام في العالم العربي
والدولي
التعاون العسكري بين موسكو وطهران يشغل
الاعلام الدولي وينظر بحرب في المنطقه
لكببح جماح التحالف فهل وصل الى نقطه لا
عوده
في فقره التحديات الاعلاميه فوكس نيوز تحت
وابل من الالتهابات بالتضليل هل الدولار
يتحكم بالمحتوى الاخباري للقناه
وفي العراق حملت السلطات ضد منتجي المحتوى
الهابط على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تثير
نقاشات حول الحريات الاعلاميه في البلاد
التعاون العسكري غير المسبوق كما وصبته
واشنطن بين روسيا وايران يشغل الاعلام
الدولي لما له انعكاسات خطيره على الامن
في المنطقه والعالم فالتعاون يقترب من ان
يصبح تكاملا عسكريا وفق التحذيرات
الامريكيه التي نقلتها
الصحيفه عن ونت وزير الدفاع الامريكي يحذر
من تنام العلاقات العسكريه الايرانيه
الروسيه التي لا يمكن تصور مدىها كلام
العود استرجاع خلال زيارته للمنطقه لطمانه
حلفاء واشنطن بالتزامها بامنهم فيما تسارع
ايران خطواتها النوويه والمحادثات النوويه
تراوح مكانها
[موسيقى]
الكثير من التقارير الاعلاميه تتحدث عن
تقديم روسيا التقنيات الحديثه لتطوير
الدفاعات ايران الجويه المتهالكه وتعزيز
قدراتها مجله
الالكترونيه نشرت تقريرا بعنوان روسيا
ترسل بكل حب طائرات الى ايران لتعزيز
العلاقات الدفاعيه وتشير المجله الى شراء
ايران المحتمل للطائرات المقاتله الروسيه
التي من شانها ان تعزز الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه القائمه بين موسكو ووهران
وتقوي قدراتها
وفيما تستمر ايران في نفيها بتزويد روسيا
بالاسلحه في حربها ضد اوكرانيا الان الا
انها لم تخفي تطلعها لتحديث ترسانتها
الجويه عبر المساعده الروسيه وذلك معرض
مناورات عسكريه تشمل مجسمات لطائرات روسيه
الصنع وتحديدا طائرات اسيو 35 اس كما نرى
هنا الفيديو الترويجي لقى تدقيقا من قبل
كبرى المؤسسات الاعلاميه الامريكيه وفيما
لم تؤكد روسيا اتفاق بيعها المقاتلات
المتقدمه لايران لان التفاصيل الوارده في
الفيديو وصور الاقمار الصناعيه تشير الى
ان اذا تتحضر لوصولها وتلك الطائرات ستشكل
نقل نوعيه في اسطول طهران الجوي الذي
يتحصن جزء منه داخل قاعده جويه تحت الارض
في محاكاه القواعد التي اشتهرت بها كوريا
الشماليه
في المقابل بات من المعروف ان ايران تزود
روسيا بتكنولوجيا الطائرات من دون طيار في
حربها ضد اوكرانيا ومن المحتمل ان ترسل
لها صواريخ باليستيه متوسطه المدى وكان
صحيفه موس جيرل الامريكيه قد كشفت الناموس
قوات تمضيا قدما في خططهم ما لبناء مصنع
جديد في روسيا يمكن ان ينتج ما لا يقل عن
سته الاف طائره مسيره ايرانيه التصميم
تطورات تكشف ان التحالف بين موسكو وطهران
متعدد الاوجه هو خطير اكثر مما كان يعتقد
تبادل الاسلحه والخبرات بين الجانبين
سيؤدي الى زياده حجم الترسانه العسكريه
لايران التي تسعى لان تصبح قوه نوويه حجم
الخطر لخصه الباحث في معهد هاتسون كان
كسبولكو محددا من ان الرد على الجوي اذا
حققته ايران قد يدفع باسرائيل للتدخل
العسكري المباشر هناك مؤشرات على ان ايران
تعمل حاليا على تطوير برنامجها للصواريخ
الباليستيه وبرنامج الفضاء وخاصه في مجال
التكنولوجيا الصاروخيه واذا مدت روسيا
ايران بالتقنيات لتطوير ترسانتها الجويه
من الجيل الرابع من الطائرات سيرفع ذلك
قدرتها من التحكم باجوائها بدرجه اعلى ولن
تتاخر روسيا في تامين الكميه اللازمه التي
كانت قد حضرتها لمصر قبل ان تعدل القاهره
عن الفكره بسبب الخ من العقوبات ناهيك عن
دمج كل تلك القدرات القتاليه الجويه في
قواعد تحت الارض لحمايتها من الاعتداءات
في منشات تحاكي نموذج كوريا الشماليه فان
ذلك سيضع ايران في مصافي الدول المهدده في
ظل سعيها الى تامين قنبله نوويه في
الاثناء
تراقبي داخل سوريا الا انها مش الحريه
يضيق بالنسبه الى اسرائيل ضرب برنامج
ايران نووي في حال حصلت على انظمه دفاع
جويه متطوره وفي قبل البرج وفق الوكاله
فان احتماليه وحصول ايران على انظمه اس
400 ستسرع من اتخاذ قرار بشان هجوم من
اسرائيلي محتمل هذا في وقت لا يبدو ان
التحالف بين موسكو وطهران يقتصر على الشق
الدفاعي بل يدخل ايضا على خط الملف النووي
الايراني الذي يراوح مكانه فاكس نيوز نقلت
عن مصادر استخباراتيه اجنبيه قولها ان
ايران ابرمت صفقه سريه مع روسيا تضمن
اعاده كميه اليورانيوم التي تم نقلها
سابقا الى موسكو لخفض مخزون ايران منه
بموجب الاتفاق النووي وتقول فوكس ان
الصفقه ابرمت خلال زياره بوتين لايران في
يوليو الماضي حيث انتهز الايرانيون الفرصه
من حاجه بوتين الماسه من دون طيار
لاستعاده مخزونها من اليورانيوم بسرعه الى
مستويات التخصيب والكميه التي امتلكتها
قبل الاتفاق وفيما تشهد التحالفات الدوليه
تغيرات عما كانت عليه ابانه الاتفاق
النووي عام 2015 لا تزال اداره بيض متمسكه
بالاتفاق النووي الايراني والذي من شانه
ان يوفر لطهران السيوله الكافيه لتحديث
رسانتها
شان الايراني جيسون يقول ان اي اتفاق لاحق
سيعطي بوتين اليد العليا في ظل ظروف
الصراع الحاليه مع مراعاته لايران بالدرجه
الاولى وبالتالي لا يمكن الوثوق بالكريم
لينك طرف في الاتفاق وعليه حان الوقت
لاعلان موت الاتفاق وتفعيل اليه اعاده
العقوبات سناب باك والتحول الى استراتيجيه
الردع
الاخطاء في الحسابات الامريكيه القت صحيفه
الضوء عليها اخطاء يقول الكاتب والتر راس
الميد في مقاله انها ستؤدي الى اندلاع حرب
في الشرق الاوسط في ماذا اقرب من المتوقع
راس المئه قال ان سعي ايران الحثيث
لامتلاك الاسلحه النوويه بالاضافه الى
شركتها العميقه مع روسيا تدفع بالشرق
الاوسط بشكل مضطرد الى الاقتراب من حرب من
المرجح ان تشترك الولايات المتحده بها رغم
محاوله تجنبها ويقول الكاتب انه فيما كانت
تحاول اداره بايدن تقليل الصراعات مع
تهميش روسيا واحتواء ايران عبر اتفاق
النووي معها للتفرغ للتهديد الصيني وجدت
نفسها امام مارد صني اقوى وذلك لان بايدن
فشل في فهم مدى ضعف القوه الامريكيه مع
ابتعادها عن حلفائها والى اي مدى اصبحت
القوه المناهضه لها كالصين وروسيا وايران
على الاستعداد للتعاون من اجل اضعاف
الهيمنه الامريكيه
فمن هنا نصل الى مقر الكاتبه راغده درغام
في صحيفه النهار التي قالت انه مع التقارب
الروسي الايراني خرجت دول اوروبيه وعلى
راسها المانيا من سرب الانبطاح امام طهران
فيما بقيت تباين بين واشنطن وحلفائها
الاوروبيين اذا اصبوا للردع على التجاوزات
الايرانيه في ملف النووي وفي اوكرانيا
قائمه وختمت بالقول المناورات العسكريه
الايرانيه الاخيره تعمدت كشف القدرات
الهائله لدى طهران تلك في الاجواء وتلك في
الانفاق فاذا في تاهب وفي مزاج الغضب
والاستعداد للسباق كذلك موسكو انها في
مزاج الرفض القاطع للهزيمه وكلتاهما متاهب
للمفاجات
وتنضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي راغده درغم من
بيروت لنسالها عن مقالها الاخير اهلا بك
استاذه راغده تقولين ان ايران جاهزه
للسباق عن اي خطوات السباقيه تتحدثين
ايران جاهزه للسباق عبر اسرائيل لانها
تخشى ان تقوم اسرائيل بالضرب مفاعلها
النوويه لكنها تراهن على ان الولايات
المتحده اداره بيض بالذات لن توافق على
التورط في عمليات عسكريه اسرائيليه ضد
المفاعل النوويه الايرانيه اذا هي تريد ان
تقول لنا طهران تريد ان تقول لنا
انها جاهزه للاشتباق بمعنى انها ستاخذ
المبادره من يضرب اولا ستكون له الاولويه
والارجحيه بالنجاح لكنها تبعث ذلك ربما
ساخن للاختبار لانها هي بدورها تخشى من ان
لا تكون على حق في افتراضها ان الاداره
الامريكيه لن تساعد اسرائيل ثم ان الاداره
الامريكيه تتمنى لو تفعل ذلك ايران لان
ذلك لانها ستوفر لها كل التفسيرات
والتبريرات لتكون بجانب اسرائيل في عمليات
كبرى اذا فعلت ايران تتبعد به وهو
العمليات الاستباقيه عن اي عمليات نتحدث
ممكن عسكريه مثلا ممكن ان تغامر عسكريا
نعم ايران يمكن ان تغامر عسكريا ام مع
اسرائيل لانها في وضع محرج جدا فهي ليست
على علاقات جيده بالاوروبيين الذين كانوا
يدافعون عنها دفاعا شرسا وذلك بسبب طورتها
في الحرب الاوكرانيه بجانب طبعا روسيه كما
نعرف
مفوضه النوويه التي كانت تعقد في فيينا
توقفت ايران تحاول ان توحي بانها جاهزه
لها لكن الازمه ما زالت ازمه كبيره سيما
من ناحيه التخصيب تخصيب مستوى تقسيب
اليورانيوم التي تقول ايران انه لم يكن
مقصودا لكن الدول الغربيه لا تصدقها في
ذلك نعم وفي المقابل البعض يقول ان ايران
بالعكس تريد ان ترطب الامور وتخفض التصعيد
مع الغرب فهي تقول انا مستعده لمناقشه
الملف النووي وتقدم بعض التنازلات للموضوع
وانها غير مستعده او غير جاهزه لاستقبال
الانظمه الدفاعيه الروسيه وهو ما تخشاه
اسرائيل وبالتالي كلها تلك مؤشرات
لاسرائيل وللغرب انها ليست بصدد التصعيد
ما ردك
اولا اعتقد ان ما تحاول ايران ان تفعله هو
نزع الفتيل انها في حاجه
لبعض الاستراحه اذا شئت من هذا التصعيد
الذي يحدث سيما في الحرب الاوكرانيه لان
هذا شهر حاسم جدا في العمليات العسكريه
الهجوميه تلك الاوكرانيه وتلك الروسيه
ايران متبرطه في علاقتها مع روسيا وهي
بالتاكيد اؤكد لك مهما قالت انها تسعى ان
تحصل على من روسيه على الاسفور هندريد
وعلى انواع اخرى من الصواريخ صحيح انها
تعطي لروسيه المسيرات لكن ما تريده من
روسيه هو اكبر بكثير من المسيرات لذلك
اعتقد ان ايران تحاول ان توحي بانها جاهزه
للعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات المشكله ان
الاطراف الغربيه ليست جاهزه
لاعاده تاهيل ايران تفاوتيا وذلك لانها
تورطت في الحرب الروسيه ضد اوروبا واو
روبا غاضبه جدا وكما ايران غاضبه كما
فلاديمير بوتين غاضب وكذلك الرئيس الغضب
استاذه نحن في حاله خطره جدا نعم تحدثت عن
عن غضب وعن حاله خطره جدا
ثلاثيه ما مع دخول ايران على خط الحرب
الاوكرانيه ماذا تتوقعين الخطوات عمل نيه
غربيه ضد ايران
عقوبات اعتقد ان في ذهن اوروبا ان تشن
حربا عسكريه على ايران ولا اعتقد ان في
ذهن الولايات المتحده التبرد بمبادره
امريكيه في عمليه عسكريه على ايران
المشكله ان هناك لربما حاجه اسرائيليه بان
تورط الولايات المتحده معها في عمليات
عسكريه وربما هذا من جهه ومن جهه ثانيه
لربما ايران هي التي تريد ان تغير
المعادله تغير
يعني ان تزيل الانظار عن داخلها عن الوضع
الداخلي الذي تعاني منه
التخلص من العقوبات
نعم وتفجر المفاجاه هي لا اعلم في الواقع
ان كانت تخوفنا او اتنوي ان تفعل ذلك
لكننا يجب ان ناخذ ما تقوله في الحساب لان
هذا زمن المفاجات الصعبه ان كان اوكرانيا
او اقليميا ايرانيا او اسرائيليا
راغده
درغام كيف تمر البريطانيه ارجلت اختبارا
حول الموضوع نعرف الاجابه بعد قليل
اهلا بكم من جديد المجموعه الاعلاميه
الامريكيه لماردو وعلى راسها فقص نيوز في
دائره اتهامات خطيره قد تعرضها لدفع غرامه
غير مسبوقه وذلك في ضوء دعوه التشهير التي
رفعتها شركه التي تزود هيئه الانتخابات
باجهزه الاقتراع الشركه تطلب من فاكس نيوز
تعويضا بمقدار مليار و600 مليون دولار
اتهمت الاضرار الحاد بسمعتها في ظل تشكيك
القناه بنتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه
او قضيه تحولت الى قضيه راي عام في امريكا
مع اتهام القناه بالتحريض على رفض نتائج
الانتخابات وبالتالي على هزء ركائز
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه القضيه عرض ضخمتها
لم تتطرق لها القناه فوكس نيوز على شاشتها
ما دفع احد مذيعها المتخصص في الشان
الاعلامي هارد سكورت في تبرير ذلك شاهدوا
معي
الادعاء على ميردوكس
واسعه النطاق تتكون من رسائل نصيه ورسائل
بريد الكتروني داخليه لاهم نجوم القناه
المحتوى للرسائل الداخليه سمح للمحامين
بربط الصله بين الجانب الاداري والجانب
التحريري في فوكس نيوز خلال فتره
الانتخابات وبعدها من خلال الوثائق
الداخليه اتضح ان الحمله الاعلاميه التي
رافقت الانتخابات ونتائجها لم تستند الى
الوقائع بل نسجت وفقا للمصالح الاقتصاديه
البحته للقناه وفق الاتهامات اذ تشير
المعلومات الى ان المحطه بامر من ملكها
كفت حملاتها لدعم ترامب لانه يتمتع بشعبيه
كبيره لدى جمهورها ومع هزيمه ترامب فعلت
القناه نظريه التلاعب بالانتخابات فلا احد
يريد معاداه ترامب وفق مقاله مردخ في
شهادته تحت القصف
وسيطره نظريه المؤامره على القناه مع ظهور
المكثف لمنظري المؤامره مثل المحامي رودي
جولياني والمحاميه سيدني باور رغم ان احد
من مذيعي القناه الرئيسيين كان على قناعه
بالموضوع كما اتضح بالمراسلات هذا لان
فقدان جزء كبير من جمهوره لقنوات اخرى مثل
نيوز ماكس
ذلك المجموعه ادلب بشهادته امام المحكمه
واقر بان العديد من نجوم التلفزيون ايدوا
عن علم تصريحات غير صحيحه ادلى بها بشان
تزوير الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه لعام
2020 ولكن هو شخصيا لا يهمه الازرق في
الاشاره الى الحزب الديمقراطي ولا الاحمر
نسبه الى الحزب الجمهوري بل كل ما يهمه
الاخضر العمله الامريكيه الدولار
وفي العراق الجدل مستمر حول الحمله التي
اطلقتها السلطات ضد منتجي المحتوى الهابط
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي والمدنون
تلقوا احكاما بالسجن لمده ترى واحد بين
شهرين وسنتين وزاره الداخليه تقول انها
تلقت 100 از بلاغ ضد ما يعد محتوى هابطا
في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي عبر منصه
استقبال الشكاوى والاخبارات التي اطلقتها
الوزاره مؤخرا لهذا الغرض تماشيا مع قرار
منع نشر اي شيء مسيء بموجب القانون
[موسيقى]
فتراوحت اذا الاراء بين مؤيد لقرارات
الحكومه بملاحقه صانعي المحتوى الهابط
والمعارضين له المعترضون يقولون ان هذه
الاجراءات تستهدف تكميم الافواه او محاربه
الحريات لكن المعترضين يتساءلون عن
المعايير التي تعتمدها الوزاره لتمييز
المحتوى الجيد من الهابط واخذت القضيه
منحى اخر بعدما كثر الحديث عن علاقات تربط
مشاهير السوشيال ميديا بضباط في الداخليه
ما خفف العقوبات عن بعضهن والان الى
اخبارنا المختصره حول جديد المشهد
الاعلامي
اظهر تقرير معهد مختصين تراجع مرتبه
الولايات المتحده من حيث نسبه الحريات
للمرتبه الثالثه والعشرين متراجعه على
المرتبه الثامنه التي كانت احتلتها لعام
2008 التقرير قارن بين 165 دوله حول
العالم من حيث الحريه الشخصيه والاقتصاديه
التراجع الامريكي اثر قلقا من تدهور
الحريات في الدوله التي كانت تتفاخر دائما
بانها ارض الحريات
اثار التطور السريع
القلق لدى العديد من الموظفين حول العالم
من خطر فقدان عملهم واستبدالهم بالتطبيق
لان اخر الابحاث اشارت الى ان الافضليه ما
زالت للبشر وذلك لانه عندما يتعلق الامر
بالكتابه والتحليل لامور حساسه لا يمكن
للذكاء الاصطناعي تقديم المعلومات
المطلوبه وتوفيرها وفق تجربه رئيس تحرير
جريده ذئب مرر البريطانيه
وبهذا نصل الى ختام الحلقه لليوم موعدنا
يتجدد الاسبوع المقبل شكرا لحسن المتابعه
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]